une invitation au voyage inspiré de ses
différents séjours solène a vécu en
guyane une région qu'elle continue de
peindre pour préparer son exposition
chez capsule markets
alors je vais présenter ce style
d'oeuvres là parce que cette cette soeur
est ce la première que j'ai montré sur
facebook et c'est grâce à elle que je me
suis dit que je pouvais en faire mon
métier parce qu'elle a beaucoup plus
donc c'est la forêt guyanaise la forêt
amazonienne et à tous qui amérindiens et
tout ça c'est complètement passionnant
et du coup les peindre pour moi c'est
vraiment une passion de la forêt
tropicale à la montagne mais aussi des
tableaux plus enfantin l'artiste fait
partie du groupe délire de créatrice qui
compte plus de 200 membres sur internet
clotilde a rejoint le groupe depuis sa
création il ya deux ans elle aussi
présentera son travail notamment ses
boîtes à bouchon le vin fait partie de
notre terroir
le terroir c'est important et on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup de gens gardent
leurs bouchons de vin j'ai découvert ça
un petit peu par hasard à la suite de
demandes de clientes que beaucoup de
personnes ont un vase impôts quelque
chose qui gardent les bouches mans et on
m'a demandé de faire une vitrine pour
les exposer le coloris de la vitrine est
complètement adapté aux désirs du client
m'a demandé du vert du bleu on m'a même
envoyé un morceau de tissu pour la
sortie aux bleus de tels rideau
on me le demande très souvent pour faire
des cadeaux pour les papas autres
spécialités pour les plus jeunes cette
fois ses marque-pages magnétique
jusqu'au 1er avril le public retrouvera
le travail de clotilde et solène parmi
les oeuvres d'une trentaine de créateurs